it's a new piece from racket news and
it's from Matt tabi he's an independent
journalist and he warns that Anthony
fauci was quote a warm-up dictator
saying this he institutionalized the
purposeful lies suppressed critics
mastered emergency politics Anthony
fauci gave the next Monster A playbook
Matty isn't talking in general terms
he's talking specific about what's been
discovered in the months after the
pandemic Matt welcome back tell me about
the proximal Origins what's been
discovered over the last few weeks that
made you say something as bold as that
well this has been a a story that's been
in the works for months now the first
stage of it came when
um Communications between the authors of
a nature medicine paper called the
proximal origins of SARS cov2 came out
these were the first scientists who said
that the disease most likely had a
natural or zoonotic origin and that Lab
Escape was unlikely
we later found out through among other
things through these papers and through
the emails that Anthony fauci was
intimately involved with the crafting of
that paper and moreover that the authors
of this paper of that paper actually had
very strong suspicions that it came from
a lab and they had to get over those
feelings to write that paper but more
recently we learned that fauci brought
that paper and may have even brought one
of the authors of that paper to the CIA
to talk to the CAA analysts he also went
to the state state department and to to
the White House and essentially was was
trying to suppress inquiry into the
origins of covid so the first White
House or the second the Trump White
House and the Biden White House correct
right and this and you know what's also
interesting Matt is the CIA still hasn't
made a decision on where it came from
but the FBI did it likely came from a
lab leak and now we find out he visits
there and which which stands out for you
about that so this obviously is a
problem when our most respected
scientist is out there putting his hand
on the scale as we try to find out the
origins of a pandemic that's killing
Millions
yeah and Brian this is such an important
point because multiple sources told us
that the reason that the department of
energy and the FBI uh came to the
conclusion they they both issued reports
saying that Lab Escape was the most
likely explanation for covet
was because they use their own uh
analysts they they use their own
researchers and did not use anybody from
the health bureaucracy they didn't use
anybody from the NIH or the Nai naiaid
uh so because they did an independent
investigation which is exactly how you
should do intelligence uh they came to
their own conclusions which is not what
apparently what Anthony found Anthony
fauci wanted and that's key I mean
without that kind of system without the
independence you're not going to come to
uh the correct conclusion so this is my
analogy you don't have to join it but
it's like a huge crowd watching a tree
fall in the woods hearing it but denying
they heard it and you're the only one
who would write this and you can't
believe outside the Wall Street Journal
the oversight committee that people
aren't just jumping on this because it's
not something that should be partisan
right I mean you know we published this
in Racket and you know we co-published
it with uh Michael schellenberger and
Alex guten tag over at public as well
um you know we were some of the same
people who worked in the Twitter files
it's we've gotten used to at this point
uh being ignored on some of these
stories but this story has nothing to do
with partisan politics this is strictly
about getting to the bottom of a of a
still open uh major news mystery which
is how did this thing happen and there's
still no official explanation and nobody
seems to be on the case and it's just
baffling Brian I just don't I just don't
understand why nobody wants to to look
at this I do our audience does Matt
thanks so much we'll keep reading it and
I'll talk to you on radio later thank
you
thanks so much all right we reached out
to Dr fauci for comment but did not hear
back and I'm shocked give me a second
now I feel better I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis